it's a fool a Capcom exclusive I
remember I talked to on the phone maybe
like two years ago man it was uh it was
right around when Kendra got that cosine
from drown on Big Boy's neighborhood and
I remember you know I've always been a
champion of the quote/unquote new West
sound whether it's you were j-rock or
Jim Malone back then like you know
there's always been a lot of talent in
Cali now the world I feel like it's
finally coming around
um and I remember that you had kind of
spoke out not necessarily in like a
negative way but kind of maybe let the
lack of support Dre had shown to that
point of these new artists that were in
the streets making noise and it seems
like like I said everyone's finally
starting to recognize what do you think
has changed since two years ago to now
to where you guys aren't fighting to get
on the radio anymore you guys aren't
like it's not it's not a struggle it's
not you know it really seemed like back
then it really was like you guys were in
LA making great music and healthy you
know the people in LA who were in a
position to support great music weren't
really doing so so what do you think has
changed oh what a speak to the first
point you talked about the arm mister
untouchable record I said I'm alright
till he died so it's [__] detox
and only thing we run is Louise bells
Delilah rods um more than anything even
though now before I even was aware that
talk dog and Kendrick little part of it
right in our situation because just
speaking realistically that's family we
toured together in 2008 we came you know
we had bar fights with other dogs other
people in clubs and Ally hopped in and
we have to in situations that there was
involved and so you know that what I
said about the you know the Dre
situation you just me being a real [__]
and speaking like I feel like a lot of
people felt that way well you're the
okay yeah and again it wasn't like a
direct shot it was just like me speaking
what was true to me at the moment like
you know we don't us and we only gonna
push regardless of cosines of help of
you know people coming down dropping
ropes but I felt like if I'm sitting
back in the game and I'm watching them
see us and I'm watching you know Don
Kennedy
and I'm watching you know yg at that
moment developing a situation I just
felt like what I was doing I wouldn't
spend money I wouldn't necessarily um
offer financial support but I would do
what I do to the him do that I see I
would acknowledge they grow right you
know I mean that's what it was about the
signal is in the ground because when is
when it's impossible to miss and you
don't acknowledge II that becomes
intentionally nothing nothing I feel
like like you said just this kind of off
but back then you were dropping records
like roll the windows up to me if that
song would have been on Interscope
Records yeah someone being huge it's
like a classic West Coast record Thanks
but yeah another thing I wanted to talk
to you about this whole Crenshaw thing
man I know that you've always always
represented your opponent that's been
very important to you throughout your
entire career man whether it's lost in
the Crenshaw the you know the sweaters
earners and all that stuff
why name a mixtape Crenshaw I feel like
almost felt like that should be like an
album like down the line yeah well I
mean again you know I said there's years
ago I might not ever release him out and
I seen recently he no chance the rapper
shout-out to him and his squad you know
that he said it in the Rolling Stone
might I have to yeah because what I what
I paid attention to was how people
consume music a lot of times the record
getting the most playing your car is a
mixtape recently yeah straight up and if
it's not the one getting the most play
it's in rotation with the other two
albums that's platinum or double
platinum and it's these guys mixtape and
what I think happens is that people make
music from different perspectives when
they when they quote unquote making a
mixtape and making it
I think a lot of times the pressure of
an album the platform that you assume
your album has to be hard on delivered
to it it gets in it gets in the way of
your process whereas a mixtape you think
about people experience in the music we
make the mix - mm-hmm cuz you think of
you dropping it on the Internet's going
straight to the people they gonna
download it and in here that's what's in
your mind when you make the next time
and so on you know to just bring him
back home I felt like the title crash on
it represented one word that you could
say Nipsey Hussle and think about in his
in his air and I just want to make a
concise and make it clear you know we
got to search everywhere you know it's
hard to be in any city state or country
now and not seeing at one point are they
talking if you involved in the culture
if you if you if you win that world if
hip-hop or even my street where a
fascist traitor and so I just felt like
for sure they see that they think nipsey
you know you know my business partners
Lords Benicia and him are my brothers
that recently made in 1991 boys in the
hood edition which is doing at home you
know it's on Slauson and calm everybody
can get me mad with it was inspired by
boys in the hood if you watch the movie
try was sitting on a on his porch and he
had on the cresol hat - logo and you
know get on a Kris or logo shirt so I
just think you know the time was right
we had just debuted the new design
you know I had a different title for the
mixtape at first but without listen to
it records like face the world records
like the how Charles Lawson in Crenshaw
true story records life blessings it
just reminded me and it sounds like it's
fits the title absolutely yeah if you
said you wanted to go back to that that
young nipsey in this your hood you know
what I'm saying yeah he was that and I
was my style actually it's more than
more to my hood I was mom my part of my
hood where I was the most plane crash
almost Lawson okay that was really the
area that you know I was known being I
was known for so a lot of factors led to
an we need you to logo up and we looked
at it it was a no-brainer like yesterday